[موسيقى]
اكبر كواكب المجموعه الشمسيه المشتري
والمع نجوم السماء اشعره وانه هو رب شعره
واشهرها نجم سهيل وسهيل كنجمه الحب في
اللون وقلب المحب في الخفقان واجمل ما
بالكون القمر وهذه الثلاث المشتري الشعره
سهيل سنشاهدها بالعين المجرده طوال هذه
الليالي المشتري بالجهه الغربيه والشعره
فوق الراس واسهيل بالجهه الجنوبيه كشفت
ثلاث ذوائم من شعرها في ليله فارط ليالي
اربعه واستقبلت قمر السماء بوجهيا طارتني
القمرين في وقت
معا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وكل ليله من هذه الليالي يقترب كوكب
المشتري من القمر واقرب مسافه بينهما
يسميه العرب بالاقتران فالجميل سيقترن مع
الكوكب الكبير المشتري اكبر من الارض ب
1200 مره والقمر اصغر من الارض باربع مرات
فلو جمعتم جمال الكون اجمعه في شخص اخرى
وقد جاءت هنا لكنت كالصخره الصماء عاطفه
وقلت هذا الجمال
ليس يعنيني
[موسيقى]